Done.
I want to turn to the next topic,
which is Mark's a new unit in our course.
That is to say until now we've dealt with bubonic plague in a series of talks
and uh,
in your first section meeting now I'd like to look for comparative purposes,
uh,
a very different high impact disease.
And this time and next we'll be dealing with smallpox.
So I think you deserve an answer to the obvious questions.
Why smallpox and why at this stage in the course.
So I want to give you a little bit of explanation,
uh,
to see where we're going.
The first has to do with a,
what I might call a varied intellectual diet.
And I want us to deal with diseases of very different types.
And so we'll have to examine the impact of different kinds of infectious
diseases.
Plague was a bacterial disease.
Smallpox instead is viral plague was transmitted by vectors.
You know the drill.
Now the role of routes and fleas.
Smallpox instead is spread by contact and airborne inhalation of droplets.
Plague is a classic epidemic disease in the sense that it's an outside invader
that ravages a locality for a season and then departs smallpox is different and
that it can be both endemic and epidemic.
So we'll see a different dynamic.
It's also true that the social responses to smallpox,
we're quite different.
Plug was associated with terror and social disruption and in the new world will
see that it had an even more dramatic impact on the native smallpox did on the
native American population.
But in European conditions it was a familiar and Dominic disease with a less
dramatic,
uh,
as a cause was less dramatic as a cause of social tensions and disruption.
We'll see to that.
In terms of impact,
uh,
for chronology,
it makes sense to look at smallpox at this stage in our class.
It had long been present in human history,
but there was an upsurge in smallpox in the 17th and 18th centuries that
accompanied the surge in dumb,
the demography of Europe.
And it also reflected the transformation of social and economic conditions
associated with the commercialization of agriculture,
the onset of industrial development and rapid unplanned urbanization.
With those associated pathologies such as overcrowding,
both at home and in the workplace.
So in those conditions,
smallpox was a great killer and it succeeded Plagge as the most dreaded disease
of the late 17th and the 18th century.
So in a sense,
we're moving from boob onic plague the most dreaded disease of its era to in a
sense in terms of fear,
uh,
to smallpox as the next most dreaded disease of the next period in the 18th
century.
But there's more to it than not.
Small pox,
as you'll see in our reading and in our lecture next time,
was also extraordinarily important in terms of its impact in the new world.
It led to a demographic catastrophe for the native American population largely
spontaneously,
but there were also intentional acts of genocide involved.
So we're going to see in terms of one of the themes of our course that disease
and particularly small pox,
played an important role in the big picture of history in conditioning or
creating factors that were important in European settlement in the new world.
And that led to the introduction of African slavery as the native American
population had new immunity and perished from small pox and therefore could not
be enslaved,
whereas Africans possessing immunity were important to replace them.
Another major feature and reason for dealing with smallpox has to do with
another theme of our course and not as public health.
We've already dealt with plague measures of public health.
You know what they are.
The plague measures boards of health quarantine,
lots of Raftos,
sanitary cordons or emergency burial regulations.
Smallpox by contrast was to lead to a very different but highly effective style
of public health.
That is first inoculation and then vaccination associated with Edward Jenner
even more spectacularly.
Then plagued measures.
Vaccination ultimately promoted a victory over smallpox leading in 1982 it's
total global eradication at least naturally occurring smallpox,
the first and still as we speak,
the only human disease to be so intentionally eradicated.
Unlike plagued measures,
vaccination was a powerful tool of public health.
Successful vaccines have subsequently been developed against other diseases.
Measles,
Rubella,
whooping cough,
tetanus,
diptheria,
rabies,
polo,
polio,
but again like plague measures.
Vaccines have been controversial and we'll be talking about when vaccines form
an appropriate strategy and eradication has been ever more elusive for diseases
other than smallpox.
It may be that smallpox is a special case rather than as many hoped on model for
the eradication of diseases sequentially.
One after another we'll be looking also out smallpox because of its demographic
and economic effects.
We talked in terms of play of a mortality revolution in terms of geography,
demography and also of its impact on industrialization,
smallpox and the successful containment of smallpox to inoculation and
vaccination also had a major impact on that mortality revolution and therefore
also on economic development.
We'll be looking also at cultural impact and we'll see that smallpox also
produced,
uh,
the cult of certain new saints that it to became a theme in the arts and
literature and more speculatively.
We talked last time about the possible relationship of the successful conquest
of plague on the coming of the enlightenment.
Well,
smallpox provides us with a second instance of the successful deployment of
human means to control a major cause of death and anguish,
making life more secure and longer.
It's suggestive that a number of leading filas off,
we're avid proponents of inoculation,
including Voltaire and conduits say,
so we'll be dealing with those issues.
But this morning what I'd like to do is to concentrate on something more narrow,
which is the nature,
but forms the basis for our understanding of the impact of this disease.
It's nature as a disease,
how it affects the individual human body.
And what were the treatments,
uh,
in the 17th,
18th centuries.
So let's begin with smallpox as a disease.
Smallpox often called nicknamed for reasons.
We'll soon see the speckled monster.
There is a,
it's a virus belonging to the family of orthopods viruses that includes very ola
major,
very ola minor and cow pox.
We'll talk about cow pox,
uh,
next time because if it's influence in the development of vaccination,
but our theme will concern very all a major and very ola minor,
especially very all a major which is the causative agent primarily of smallpox.
This is a picture of very old nature,
the largest of all viruses,
first seen by the microscope in 1905.
This causes classical smallpox.
There's very old,
a minor as well.
That first appeared in the 20th century and work for our purposes,
we can afford to ignore it.
It was of minor impact and now like very old major,
it's extinct as well.
Now one question is what's a virus?
We talked about the term microbe micro being the generic term from microscopic
organisms including bacteria like our friend Yersinia Pestis,
the causative agent of Boob,
onic plague and viruses like very all a major and very ola minor.
The pathogens that cause smallpox plague,
which caused by bacteria and those as you know,
and we'll be studying more on science hill,
our union cellular organisms that are definitely and unequivocally alive,
they reproduce by dividing.
They contain DNA plus all the cellular machinery necessary to read it and to
produce the many proteins,
the enable it to live and reproduce.
Viruses are something different and here there's a possible confusion lurking
for the historian.
The word virus itself is ancient in the humeral system.
In fact,
when diseases were seen to arise from assaults on the body on the outside,
one of the major environmental insults that was thought to lead to disease was
the corrupted air or Miasma.
And this was influenced by a poison that might be called a virus.
So if you do research on medical history,
you'll see the term virus used in an old sense for many centuries.
But the virus in present medical discourse is a term that dates it's modern
usage from the early 20th century,
and it refers to parasitic particles,
perhaps 500 times smaller than bacteria.
Their existence was established by elegant scientific experiments,
uh,
in the first years of the century,
completed by about 1903,
but they couldn't actually be seen until the invention of the electron
microscope and the 1930s and they're functioning wasn't understood until the DNA
revolution of the 1950s.
So viruses we now know,
consist of some of the elements of life stripped to their most basic of virus
really is nothing more than a piece of genetic material route.
In a protein case,
there are particles that are interrupt on their own.
Viruses lock the machinery to read DNA or to make proteins or carry out
metabolic processes.
They can do nothing on their own and they cannot reproduce by themselves.
Their survival depends in stead on invading living cells.
Once inside they hijack the cell and its machinery.
The genetic code of the virus and the virus after all is almost nothing else
gives the cell the message that needs to reproduce more virus,
thus transforming cells and to virus producing factories.
And in the process they destroy the host cell.
As they produce more and more viruses and destroy more and more cells,
the effect on the human body can be severe,
even catastrophic depending on the capacity of the immune system to contain or
destroy the invasion.
So here we have an esense,
the opposite of a hippocratic idea of disease.
The body assaulted not from the outside,
but rather from a parasitic pathogen.
Deep within there is an exotic debate,
of course,
are viruses alive.
Those argue that they are alive,
not that they're capable of transmitting genetic material.
One of the key indications of life.
Those who claim they're not alive,
note that on their own there are nerves that they can't carry on metabolic
processes or produce proteins.
Viruses they know are the ultimate parasites.
Virologists often say that whether you decide that viruses or alive or not is
ultimately a matter of disciplinary perspective or perhaps even personal
preference.
The re reassuring point for us as it perhaps accepting theology,
the answer doesn't really matter in any case,
what we need to know is that smallpox was caused by a virus and a virus that has
no animal reservoir.
The disease was restricted entirely to human beings and that will prove to be
important in making it eventually a good candidate for eradication.
The name for the virus,
Vario,
Lola,
derives from the Latin,
various meaning spotted.
And in England,
the disease in fact was popularly called,
as I've said,
the speckled monster.
So here's the picture of the smallpox.
Oops,
it's going out.
There it is.
And that's a schematic,
um,
uh,
image of a smallpox virus.
And as I said,
there is a mutation that occurred in the 20th century calling causing the rise
of Arriola minor as well as Vario,
all major,
but we'll be concerned exclusively here with Vario,
the main cause of smallpox historically.
Well,
how was it transmitted
here?
We need to remember that smallpox is an exceedingly contagious disease.
A smallpox patient sheds millions of infective viruses into his or her immediate
surroundings from the rash and from the open sowers and the sufferer's throat.
The patient is infective from just before the onset of the rash until the very
last scab falls off weeks later.
Not everyone of course,
who is exposed as infected living along with people with immunity and leaving
that aside,
it has been estimated that the chances are about 50 50 that is susceptible
member of a household would contract smallpox from an ill patient in the home.
The dominant mounter of spread manner to spread smallpox was by contact.
Infection droplets breathed out in face to face contact with a susceptible
person and inhaled by that person.
Normally the spread was in the context of intense contact over a period of time
that is a family member or someone on a hospital ward in an enclosed workplace,
an office,
a factory,
a mine,
the school classroom and army barrack or refugee camp.
And it's most easily transmitted in dry cool seasons.
That's the primary mode of transmission.
There are two more,
however,
that are,
uh,
more relatively secondary.
A second mode of transmission is by what are called another bit of jargon here.
Fomites a phone might is simply an inanimate object capable of carrying
infectious material from one person to.
Another.
Examples might be bed linen clothing,
the shroud from an infected person that transmits viruses from one body that is
of the sufferer to the next person.
Other examples are simply doorknobs,
eating utensils,
and so on.
So that's the second mode of transmission.
There's a third to that.
Smallpox can be vertically transmitted.
That is from mother to infant.
So it's possible for an infant to be born with congenital small punks.
Well,
if that's the mode of transmission.
What about its epidemiology?
Well,
some favoring factors include large urban populations.
It's not coincidental that smallpox raged in western Europe in the 18th century.
Good,
crowded living conditions and workplaces where ideal for its transmission trade
and the movement of people,
displaced people,
warfare,
people who assembled and reassembled in crowds were ideal for transmitting
smallpox.
The disease is known to have afflicted ancient Egypt.
Um,
mummies are known to have been victims of smallpox,
but the important point is that it became endemic in Europe.
That became the world reservoir of infection from which it's spread by trade,
colonization,
warfare,
and in European cities.
It became above wall a disease of childhood,
but about a of the deaths of children and the 17th century where due to
smallpox.
So a reason then for dealing with smallpox now in our course is not,
it was a major upsurge in the 17th and 18th centuries.
How was it named?
Why is it called smallpox?
A small point,
but we need to know that it's from a comparative description of its
characteristic legions.
The great pox is a disease we'll be dealing with a pretty soon,
which was syphilis that creates large legions and affects adults.
The smallpox had small lesions and primarily affected children,
at least in countries in which it was endemic.
Another point we should know about smallpox is that after infection,
a person enjoys a lifelong immunity.
We need to know that because it's a major factor in the public health measures
that the disease eventually generated.
Well,
what about its symptoms?
How does it affect the individual human body
will after inhaling the virus,
there's an incubation period which normally lasts something like 12 days.
This is important and it's epidemiology because it allowed the spread of the
disease because an infected person had ample time to travel before falling ill
and therefore time to take the disease with him or her and to spread it.
Now I'm going to give some attention perhaps more than you might like when you
see the images to the symptoms of smallpox and there's a reason for that part is
that smallpox is tremendously,
terribly terrifyingly painful.
Plus it leads,
and this is important too and the way that an impacted society,
it often produces lifelong scarring,
disfiguring and blindness and these in turn spread it fear of it and terror.
And so the very word smallpox has a particular resonance in popular imagination
associated with dread.
People sometimes ask,
and of course like this,
which of the diseases we encounter was really the worst.
The question doesn't permit empirical verification because no one has ever
suffered mercifully all the afflictions we study and had the opportunity to
compare,
but it is meaningful to note the impression of those who lived through the times
when smallpox claimed it's legions of victims they thought,
and the physicians,
you treated them that smallpox was the worst of human maladies.
That was a term that was set at the time,
and this in fact was the view closer to home of the Illinois State Board of
Health in 1902 where Donald Dr. Donald Hopkins wrote this and the suddenness and
unpredictability of it's a tack and the grotesque torture of its victims and the
brutality of its lethal or disfiguring outcome and in the dread that it inspired
smallpox is the worst.
It's unique among human diseases to the extent that that's true.
It's also one of the reasons that smallpox appeals to the malevolent as a
possible instrument of bioterror.
It's well known that a major outbreak of smallpox would spread death,
maximize suffering and lead to widespread fear flight and social disruption.
The symptoms are important to examine as an integral part of this disease and
more generally,
unless we appreciate the distinctive symptoms of each of the diseases we
examined,
there's a distorting temptation to allow them to run together the diseases as so
many interchangeable causes of death or point of view that prevents us from
understanding that each of these epidemic diseases,
how to distinctive and different imprint smallpox was the disease that it was in
part because of the dread that it generated fear not only of death,
but also of exquisite suffering,
maiming disfiguring and blindness.
Only.
With that in mind,
can we understand why it's also,
uh,
so widely thought to be accounted it for bio terror?
So we'll look at images of the disease and I apologize to those of you who've
just finished breakfast are just about to have lunch.
In any case,
uh,
first after the incubation period,
there's the pre eruptive stage.
The virus multiplies in the system for 12 days after incubation and symptoms of
disease begin with a viral shower.
As the pathogen is released into the bloodstream and spreads systemically
throughout the body,
localizing eventually and the blood vessels of the skin just below the
superficial layers.
The viral reload released and the efficiency of the body's immune response
determine the severity and type of the disease onset is sudden with fever of a
hundred to 102 degrees and a general malaise.
This stand is the beginning of perhaps a month of excruciating suffering and the
danger of spreading contagion.
The early symptoms are fever,
vomiting,
severe backache,
splitting,
frontal headache,
and in children,
sometimes convulsions.
Sometimes the disease is so overwhelming that it leads to what's called
fulminating smallpox,
which causes death within 36 hours with no outward manifestations at all.
Although postmortem exams reveal hemorrhages and the respiratory tract,
the alimentary tract or the heart muscles.
Let me give you a description of a hyper acute case of that kind.
Physicians wrote after three to four days.
The general the patient has the general aspect of someone who's passed through a
long and exhausting struggle.
His face has lost.
All expression is mask like and there's a want of tone in all muscles.
When he speaks,
this condition becomes more apparent.
Speaking is with evident effort and the voice is low,
a monotonous.
The patient has listless and indifferent to surroundings.
The mental attitude is similar.
There's a loss of tension,
a lengthening of reaction time and effective control and the most four minute
cases.
The aspect of the patient resembles that of someone suffering from severe shock
and loss of blood.
The face is drawn and pallid respiration is sign or gasping.
The patient tosses about continually and cries out.
His attention is fixed with difficulty and he complains only of agonizing pain
now in the chest now in the back,
the head or the abdomen,
but normally smallpox wasn't four minute quite like that and passed.
The patient passed on to the next phase which was the eruptive one exhibiting
the classical symptoms of smallpox that led to its diagnosis on the third day
after onset.
The patient usually felt a little better and in mild cases he or she could
return to normal activities with the unfortunate effect that this spread the
disease further.
But concurrently a rash appeared,
a small round or oval rose colored lesion,
none.
As a Mac you'll that's up to a quarter of an inch in diameter.
The molecules appeared first on the tongue and palate and then within 24 hours
it spread to cover the body down to the palms of the hands and soles of the feet
on the cheek and forehead,
the appearances of severe sunburn and indeed the sensation felt by the patient
is of scalding pain or intense burning.
There is a characteristic pattern called centrifical distribution.
That is that the rash is least spread on the trunk of the body and most densely,
uh,
apparent on the face and the extremities.
Let me show you a slide,
a very ill little boy and you can see this centrifical pounder and we're in
which the,
uh,
rash is most apparent on the extremities rather than the trunk on day two of the
rash,
a little further into the infection,
the lesions alter.
Um,
the at this time,
the molecule becomes harder and generally rises above the surface into
structures known as populates with a flattened apex to the touch.
They were said by physicians to feel like buckshot embodied in the skin.
And there we can see the picture of a face,
uh,
at that stage of the disease.
The disease then moves on by the fifth day of the rash when fluid begins to
accumulate and pockmarks which are then raised and firm to the touch.
So we'll pass on now called vesicles.
They've grown in size,
they've changed in color from red to bluish or purple and they've transformed to
solid from solid to blister like fluid.
It's umbilicated as well.
The process of what's called [inaudible].
The rise of this stage of the rash takes about three days and lasts a further
three.
It's at this stage at the physical diagnosis of smallpox becomes reliable with
the disease presenting its most distinctive appearance,
the patient experiences,
increasing difficulty in swallowing and in talking you too lesions and the
mucous membranes and the palate and the throat and uh,
there's a child,
uh,
at this stage of the disease.
Then by the sixth day of the rash,
Pos begins to form in the pockmarks.
The patient feels much worse.
Septicemia can set in the puss jewels as they're now called begin to fill with
yellow fluid and the lesions become globular in shape.
A process that takes about two days and is fully there,
fully matured on the eighth day of the eruptive phase.
The patient feels dreadful at this point.
Fever has written in proportion to the severity of the attack.
The eyelids,
lips,
nose and tongue are tremendously swollen and we can see
a picture of an adult at that phase of the uh,
the infection.
At this point,
the patient is almost totally unable to swallow or talk and deteriorate slowly
being drowsy most of the time and restless at night.
Often he or she is in a condition of delirium and thrashes about me even tried
to escape the psychological effects weren't simply a sign of high fever.
They resulted also from the involvement of the central nervous system in the
infection and the neurological effects and [inaudible] could often be lasting
and result in long term impairment done by the ninth day of the rash.
The puss fuels were from and embedded in the skin.
And for this reason we're likely in this was important in the impact of the
disease to leave permanent scars and deep pits on the face or wherever they
appeared on the Bondi.
If you can imagine by um,
uh,
at this stage.
Another unpleasant aspect at this stage was that a terrible sickly smell
developed the Federer of smallpox that physician claimed that it was impossible
to describe but was found to be overpowering.
It's now nearly impossible for the patient to drink and even milk caused intense
burning sensation in the throat.
The patient experience is great loss and weight as much as 30 to 40 pounds and
an adult and may suffer from frank starvation.
In addition,
there's a complete loss of muscle tone while the face in severe cases takes on
the appearance of a cadaver,
making the patient almost unrecognizable even to his or her closest relatives,
the scalp,
maybe one large lesion and tangled with here and lesions.
As you can imagine under the nails of fingers and toes were exquisitely painful.
And then I want to show another disturbing image,
but this was important.
Uh,
though you can look away if you like,
which was uh,
the lesions of the eyes because smallpox was a major cause of blindness as well
as death and disfigurement in this period.
Well after about 10 to 14 days of rare scabs are pure and these contain live
smallpox virus as well and are highly effective,
ineffective,
and important in the spread of the disease by fomites.
At this point,
the fluid portion of the postural is absorbed,
leaving behind the solid part.
Large areas of the skin make begin to peel off,
leaving deeper tissues raw and exposed.
These areas are all painful and contribute to the frightening appearance and the
misery of the patient.
Fatal cases often occurred from about the eighth day and an important reason was
toxemia because these lesions were susceptible to infection.
So attentive nursing,
good hygiene and sound nutrition reduce the likelihood of that sort of
complication.
And to that degree,
at least the prosperous,
the wound nurse and well cared for,
we're more likely to survive.
The appearance of the patient was often described by physicians as
mortification.
There's still living patient taking on the appearance of being mummified and the
skin of the face fixed in a grotesque mess with the mouth permanently open.
The appearance of scabs and crusting though was a favorable sign in terms of
prognosis for the patient.
But they did lead to one final tournament of the disease,
which was an intolerable itching that accompanied that period.
Indeed,
a Marge portion of the scarring that resulted from smallpox was undoubtedly due
to patient's scratching and tearing at their lesions where the appearance and
distribution of the postures was of major importance for diagnosis.
And it could be what was called discreet small where the rash was.
Um,
each lesion was distinct and separated from the next.
And this meant that you had a case fatality rate of as low as about 9% you had a
90% chance of survival.
If instead the lesions were much closer together,
semi confluent,
it was called the case fatality rate rose to something like 37% or in cases of
what was called confluence smallpox in which the lesions touched one another and
formed a network surrounded by islands of unaffected skin.
The case fatality rate was about 65%
so the appearance of the lesions was very important in your prognosis.
The rarest form was hemorrhagic smallpox,
which had 100% mortality,
so called because the natural clotting mechanisms of the blood were impaired and
the victim died of massive internal hemorrhaging.
Overall,
the case fatality rate for smallpox was estimated to be about 30 to 40% the
virus then attacked not only the skin and the throat,
but also the lungs,
the heart,
the liver,
and other internal organs and could result in hemorrhaging and death.
A major danger was also secondary bacterial infection of the lesions,
a very common cause of mortality.
Meanwhile,
the lesions of the mouth and throat were of great epidemiological importance
because they're the source of the viruses that commonly formed droplets in the
air and in fact others also,
the tongue became swollen and ms shapen,
there was difficulty breathing.
The patient became course swallowing was difficult and all of that was important
and there were other sources of anguish and suffering,
blindness,
scarring and disfigurement,
respiratory complications,
but after the drawing up of the rash,
the patient began to recover and among the population that survives,
the symptoms declined and the patient regains strength and possessed a lifelong
immunity from a second exposure.
All of this led,
of course,
as you can imagine,
to tremendous fear of the disease as in this picture of Arriola.
Well,
how did physicians deal with this disease?
Smallpox no longer occurs naturally anywhere on the planet,
but it's worth remembering that there is still no specific remedy or cure for
the disease.
Treatment.
Should a case appear today would be largely supportive depending as Volvo on
intensive nursing to keep the lesion scrupulously clean,
to prevent bedsores,
and to minimize the breakdown of the skin.
In addition,
modern medicine would replace lost fluids and nutrients and would administer
antibiotics not to deal with the virus,
but with the bacterial infections that are its complications.
But what were traditional remedies?
Some of them were surprising.
One was a great vogue in the color red.
There was a vogue to hang red curtains around the bed of a patient.
Read furniture was broadened to the sick from,
and patients including Queen Elizabeth,
the first of England were wrapped in red bank blankets.
Later on,
the discovery of ultraviolet rays,
in fact,
gave new impetus to this traditional mania for red and red glass went up on
windows in the late 19th century.
Medical journals were published.
Studies suggesting also that red light could be soothing to the eyes of the
sufferer and that perhaps it prevented scarring of the skin.
So that was one factor.
Another idea that was very common was to open the postural with a golden needle
to drain the fluid.
And then sometimes,
uh,
the lesions were cauterized and an attempt to prevent scarring procedures that
were exceedingly painful.
The next idea was what was called the hot regimen to pile the sufferer with
blankets to induce him or her just sweat profusely to rid the body of the over
abundant humor or the patient could be immersed in a hot bath light and fresh
air according to this therapeutic fashion were deemed to be harmful and the
patient was kept in the dark if possible,
with minimal ventilation.
Sunlight was said to aggravate the disease and increased scarring and sometimes
patients were given an internal notification.
So terrifics to help the evacuation of the excess humor humor.
The opposite was also tried the so called cold regimen to keep the room cool and
frequently just sponge down the patient with cold water to place icebags on the
face.
Then there was purging and bloodletting.
Uh,
there was also the administration of opiates in the 19th century and especially
morphine to calm the patient in delirium is stringent eye drops.
We're resorted to an a particular leap.
Perverse theory with no empirical basis was the idea that on the face could be
reduced or prevented by causing more intense irritation of the skin elsewhere so
that mustard,
plasters,
mercury,
and corrosives were applied on the back in order to save the face.
There are also all kinds of local applications to the face to try to prevent
scarring.
Nitrate of silver mercury,
Aja Dean,
mild acids,
a lotion of sulfur.
All of those had their vogues.
There are ointments and compresses of virtually every substance known to men.
Some physicians held the theory that there preparations would soften the lesion
and mitigate scarring,
so indeed ingenious doctors applied lint,
boric acid or glycerin,
or they covered the face with a mask leaving holes for the eyes,
nose,
and mouth,
where they wrapped the face and hands in oiled silk.
Alcoholic beverages were administered to deteriorating patients to revive their
energy and sometimes delirious patients were actually tied to their beds.
Some doctors recommended restraints such as splints and later stages to prevent
patients from scarring and faces by scratching.
After hearing of all of these treatments for smallpox,
perhaps you'll appreciate the work of Thomas signum in the 17th century.
Uh,
the so called English Hippocrates,
who decided that the wealthy and noble who received extensive attention and
treatment for smallpox perished of the disease more frequently than the poor who
had no access to treatment.
And He,
his advice was that the best physician was the one who did the least.
It was an advocate of therapeutic minimalism.
He advised instead a simple,
cool regimen giving his patients fresh air and light bed coverings.
Well,
that's how the disease afflicted the human body.
What I want to do next time,
now that we understand this terrible disease and the suffering at cause is to
deal with its impact historically it's effect on society.
And to look at the development of a public health strategy,
which was to be vaccination.